he's an American former major league
shortstop who played 20 seasons with the
New York Yankees he's won five World
Series championships and is considered
one of the greatest players of his
generation he's finished six all-time in
career hits and first among shortstops
he's Derek Jeter and here are his top
ten rules for success one thing I've
always prioritized my number-one
priority for the last 20 years was my
baseball career that's it I did a lot of
other things but I never wavered from
that being my number one goal and and
I'm always big in setting goals and
trying to reach those goals and working
hard and there's there steps along the
ways along the way so I think
prioritizing is the number one thing I
think sometimes people have so many
different goals and they're going in
this direction that direction and they
never reached the potential of one
particular avenue that they're going so
I mean throughout my career I've been
very involved in different businesses
and marketing and foundation but my
number one priority was always the game
and now my priorities changed so I can
focus on some other things Center Jeter
out you know
it always been focused on work ethic
always been taught there's there's
always going to be someone that's better
but there's no reason why so much that I
work and I think that applies not only
to sports but it applies to anything
that you're trying to do you have to
work harder than other people you want
to be the best and down you'll never be
satisfied you know I never satisfy
always try think what I can do next to
be better
you have to win here that that's the
bottom line is is what have you done
lately you know we've were able to
accomplish a lot of good things early on
we've been in the postseason every year
so far but the bottom line is when
you're competing you want to win and
that's why you're out there finishing
second finishing third going to the
postseason is not good enough I think
everyone should have that mentality when
you go into a season you weren't a
championship where it doesn't mean
anything
have you always had that kind of
mentality even before he got to New York
or did it no question now I was younger
you know I always wanted my daddies to
beat me at everything we did he wouldn't
let you win oh no I wouldn't let me win
so now I don't let anyone else win so uh
you know I've always had that mentality
it's it's just it's pointless and from
my point of view if you're competing you
know
family they're the ones that have a very
close family and you know I've always
been very supportive more importantly
I've always been very honest you know I
think a lot of times people in general
like to surround themselves with people
that are gonna tell them that everything
they're doing is right you know I mean
you need people around you're going to
tell you when you're doing wrong and you
know my parents are very very honest
even if I don't want to hear something
they'll tell me they'll give me their
opinion
so I'd say family is its most important
and then secondly your friends it's the
same thing I think you know your friends
are the ones that are gonna help you
they're the ones that are going to
support you at times are gonna be the
ones that gets you in trouble so you
have to make sure that you surround
yourself with good group of friends
groceries and Cheetos they're cheater
makes the catch and they gave him the
alcohol and brochures
I don't know what the ruling is
what sexist eater was in the crowd
but Derek Jeter made it
see his with his waste on the railing
down the third base line
into the crowd and the ball and
something from watching mr. Torre for
all these years you know you always hear
that phrase would treat everyone the
same well it's not correct and treat
everyone fairly and try to be the same
every day you don't come and hold your
head up high when things are going well
and when things are going bad you find a
way to hide leadership I don't think is
something that's appointed I think it's
something that's hard
I have a lot of confidence I think you
have to have confidence in your ability
I mean I think the stronger you are
mentally I think the better you're going
to perform so I've always had confidence
anytime a minute situation I fight I
tend to look back and think back to
times that I had success and I think
that's that's helped me out there
I'm fans of athletes from all different
sports I've never tried to emulate
anything else I've tried to be myself
I've learned a lot from watching guys
you know especially guys when I was
younger but I think in terms of
leadership I think leadership is viewed
differently by different people I mean
there's there's people that lead by
example
there's people that are local leaders
people that do a little bit of both
I think you just have to be who you are
yeah how are you categorize your
leadership a little bit of both you know
I'm you know I really try to take the
time to get to know the people that I'm
leading I think that's most important
you know I was I don't think you walk
around as a self-proclaimed leader you
know I think if you do things the right
way you're honest with people you know
people may tend to follow but you know I
don't put on a show I don't do things in
front of a camera you know I've had
plenty of conversations with teammates
behind closed doors and you know I've
always heard all you're not vocal he's
now hopefully just lead by example but
you know how would people know unless
they're behind closed doors so I don't
know I have no problem with that I like
a but I like I said I think that the
most important aspect of leadership is
getting to know the people that you're
leading
what's your message to take six nowadays
are playing playing sport equivalents
baseball or in sport what's your message
to the youth of today have fun playing
you know I think kids nowadays will
specialize in a particular sport at such
an early age
you know I used to go outside and play
every game now you don't really see
results I plan they're all inside
playing video games there's a time and
place for everything but I said go out
play as many boys as you can be active
and enjoy yourself have fun and you
can't lose sight of the fact that it is
a game you're supposed to enjoy yourself
how as they wouldn't build inspiration
Dave was for those of you that don't
know I think you see only a draft
there's all three sports for anyone here
that thinks they're good athletes to
kick the game here today but he was an
inspiration maybe because he is one of
the diverse athletes to start his own
foundation and that's the idea
inspiration of my own foundation because
when I was younger I read up on Dave one
that he liked
leaps out the left field could be a
tough play Jeter on the road makes the
play
what a play by Derek Jeter
she's really
Wow
you're gonna struggle is the bottom
money I don't care how good you are
you're gonna fail I mean you failed
seven out of ten times you you go to the
Hall of Fame you know what I mean so I
was talking to a group of my leaders
once and and this was right around the
time I got 3,000 hits and I said I'll
have 3,000 hits but I've gotten out
seven seven thousand times you know to
me so it's not funny it's funny but we
get out quite a bit so I've always just
tried to remember the good times and you
have to have a very short memory you
have to stay positive but you know I
don't care what career you're in you're
gonna fail you're gonna have tough times
you know people always look at people
that when they're successful and they
assume they just woke up and they ended
up in that position but there's a lot of
speed bumps along the way it's just your
job to try to make that speed bump not
be a roadblock you know what I mean but
you have to learn from your mistakes and
move on and stay positive and and
mistakes I think you can learn more I
always tend to learn more from people's
failures than their success trying to
have that approach
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jacob Rodriguez
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of their Jeter's top 10
points you liked the most
leave it in the comments I will join in
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon